uh I don't have to tell you probably but
I will just mention it again this
upcoming four year period is going to be
a period of very high risk for
progressives and for clear thinking
individuals but actually for everybody
because in spite of the fact that more
than around 75 percent of the country of
the eligible voters did not vote for
Donald Trump about twenty-five percent
voted for Hillary Clinton about fifty
percent didn't vote at all uh the
reality is that everybody's going to be
affected by the actions taken by the
incoming president donald administration
and at the david packard show the last
week five days have been filled with
phone calls and discussions with other
non-corporate independent media sources
and we've got something really major
planned we are going to be launching a
fundraiser soon I've been mentioning it
and I'm going to continue to mention it
we are going to be doing a major
fundraiser one of the great things that
we are going to do is in addition to the
great production team that we have built
here we are going to have a progressive
engagement coordinator and this is going
to be someone that is going to be
talking to us on the show but also
importantly working behind the scenes
not only with us and our social media
platforms but also with those of many
other independent progressive shows to
concentrate the attention of
progressives on specific issues we can
take do we need to all call our
representatives about a certain is issue
well we are going to coordinate that
that do we need to all get together and
donate to particular candidates in
specific districts Senate House races
etc that are of significant consequence
nationally we are going to be
coordinating that we are going to be
doing all of that and this is just one
of the things that we will be raising
money for in our upcoming fundraiser if
you want to be an early donor to the
campaign please get in touch and I will
put you on an early notification list
ideally the early donors would be the
big donor so we can really get a head
start on the fundraising in the meantime
please check out the 2017 david pakman
show calendar it is a cartoon and comic
book themed calendar with art design by
david pakman show viewer and fan
and Burke the artwork is fantastic uh
all of your favorite about favorite and
least favorite political officials uh uh
elected officials exist Pat Robertson is
in this thing it is really a great piece
I think this is the best calendar that
we've done and you can get just the
calendar or you can get the calendar for
free at david pakman.com slash calendar
17 free with a membership check that out
if you just want a membership you can
get a forty percent discount by using
coupon code I voted 17 that's something
we set up after the election of
president elect Donald uh we are going
to be really ramping up our efforts here
coordinating with other shows a lot of
great things coming but we do need your
support